we've had another horrible school
shooting this time in Santa Fe Texas not
Santa Fe New Mexico 2018 has now been
deadlier for school children as a result
of shootings than for military
servicemembers but we'll get to that a
little bit later in the show at this
particular shooting ten people died ten
were wounded at this Santa Fe Texas
school 17 year old shooter was using a
pistol and a shotgun both of which were
taken from his father we will talk about
that element as well eventually the
shooter was taken into custody by police
not killed which I mean you know that
there's never really anything good about
these shootings but I always tend to
think it's better when we get the
perpetrator alive because of the insight
that it can provide into who knows what
the shooter reportedly told people in
classrooms I'm going to kill you and
admitted to the shootings to police
according to a statement from police
handling the investigation in addition
to the pistol and to the shotgun
explosive devices were found at the
school as well as off campus as well as
a Molotov cocktail so let's go back to
the guns briefly does the fact that the
father's guns were taken by someone else
mean that the father has some
responsibility in the sense that he
didn't properly secure the guns maybe in
Texas not likely that we would see
charges although also not impossible
mental illness as usual mental illness
is mentioned often a real issue of
course to varying degrees but it's not
always the issue which guns aside would
still lead to the same number of mass
shootings right if we want to talk about
mental health we've got to talk about
other things as well some saying well
the shooters father is an immigrant from
Greece so so what right I mean that's
been mentioned that seems to me a little
bit silly at some point everyone's
parents were immigrants to the u.s.
weren't they right like how far back can
we go if I came to the u.s. at age five
Argentina which I did and I commit a
crime now is my being an immigrant a
factor in the commission of that crime
or for example a friend of mine has
grandparents who came to the United
States if he commits a crime is the fact
that his grandparents were immigrants a
factor I mean it's hard to imagine it it
becomes a very very gray area in some
way you'd have to be a Native American
then to be absolved from any base yeah
exactly which is which is you know I get
that it's a reductio ad absurdum but
it's actually absurd even without
reducing it right and as usual securing
schools as being mentioned again this is
particularly interesting in this case
because when you look at this shooting
the school had an active shooter plan
the school not only had an active
shooter plan but they practiced with
these mock active shooter scenarios the
school had two armed police officers at
the school who were involved in the
response and yet ten people died and of
course we could make the case and people
are making the case that only 10 people
died because of the two armed police
right that the death toll would have
been even higher than 10 were it not for
the armed police and that's actually
possible but what's clear is that two
armed cops didn't prevent 10 people from
dying it's still a horrible mass
shooting one of the worst so then we get
back to well what if the teachers had
been armed then they wouldn't need to
depend on the armed officers to storm in
and save them and of course
theoretically as is the case with much
of these gun ideas from the right it's
possible right but what's not mentioned
by too many of these people who claim to
want to prevent shootings is that if it
were just more difficult for this kid to
have accessed the guns none of it would
have happened which in this case goes
back to the dad right sometimes it goes
back to failure to report reasons why
someone shouldn't have a gun to the
federal registry not federal registry of
guns but rather to the federal database
of people who should not have firearms
and there are questions in this case
because the guns came from the dad about
whether the dad will be charged but the
saddest thing here is that even those
who
choose to put the focus on anything
other than guns they don't do it in good
faith because they don't actually want
to deal with the issue and I'll give you
an example
those who say mental health is the
problem very common on the right as soon
as you've got a shooter assuming of
course that it's not a terrorist which
we know is very very related to the
identity of the shooter if we say this
was a lone nut' mental health is the
problem we've got to focus on that well
where's the funding for guaranteed
access to mental health services buying
a gun is way cheaper than going to see a
psychiatrist even with insurance in many
cases we don't guarantee access to any
healthcare that would even lead to a
primary care doctor saying you know you
came in here for a physical complaint I
think there might be a mental health
issue here and saying what about
speaking to a mental health professional
buying guns and bullets is cheaper than
getting the mental health services for
many people but the same people saying
this is a mental health problem don't
actually want to devote any money which
we would need to do to deal with the
mental health problem if you're serious
about treating this as a mental health
issue
why aren't you lobbying for funding for
mental health resources these people are
disgusting and I wasn't kidding when I
said the thing about at least more
people didn't die there are folks all
over the place if you look online saying
only 10 people died this is a win
because of those officers the people who
say they want schools to be safe won't
support devoting resources to mental
health and are celebrating this as a
victory because only 10 children died
and then this is just beyond the pale
but there are locals in the area who
have been interviewed who have been
saying the problem is the lack of
religion in schools that caused this and
there was also a guy with an American
flag and a make America great again hat
and a gun who walked by the site of the
shooting and was interviewed I mean look
at the level of clown clown hood that is
going on here
to the school making America great again
but by doing what we were opposed your
plan of action offering support you just
got bless you all but we go a long ways
right now for a lot of people thank you
I'm gonna head this way
god bless y'all and you see the gun we
need prayers okay we need prayers this
idiot is walking down the street with a
damn pistol on his side but we just had
kids get shot okay I'm a gun rights
person I have guns okay
but this idiot is walking down here and
saying that he needs to make America
great again that's not what America
needs America needs prayers we don't
need this crap all these people are off
their rockers right I mean yet the guy
with the pistol who said as soon as I
heard there was a shooting I said we've
got to make America great again so he
shows up with a gun a make America great
again hat and a flag that guy's nuts but
the guys saying we don't need pistols we
need prayers prayers and churches have
not stopped Church shootings the
shootings happened literally as people
were praying and the prayers do nothing
to keep kids safe in the future and the
prayers do nothing to bring these kids
who died back to life and one other
example someone someone named Sarah
Tassin said it's not the guns it's the
people it's a heart problem we need to
bring God back into the schools I don't
even know pat if we should be talking
about that because on the one hand it's
so irrelevant
these are the rantings of lunatics but
at the same time it's common enough that
people say such crazy stuff that I'd be
doing something wrong if I didn't at
least tell the audience that some people
are reacting in that way yeah the
thoughts and prayers line just makes
people do you think that if we think
about this problem long enough and it'll
go away
yeah and that's not happening and they
don't actually want religion in school
by the way they want Christianity in
school they're not even being genuine
about what they want they want their
religion there and their religion of
course Christianity hasn't stopped
shootings in churches so why would it
stop shootings in schools and what's
very clear and this is this is the sick
reality we're no closer to solving this
problem than we were the day after the
Sandy Hook shooting other than the
activism from the Parkland students
which it seems like is going to continue
and hopefully carry over into voter
registration for 2018 the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership